okay once again I can't believe I have
to do this but there are lies being told
by people on the left about the 2020
Democratic primary polls and I'm getting
endless messages on all platforms from
people who are either telling or
believing the lies saying David none of
the polls of the 2020 Democratic primary
that show Joe Biden leading are accurate
why because all of them are polling only
old people and Joe Biden only does well
in polls that are only of old people and
it's just not true and I'm going to
prove it to you in a second but please
just stop okay I'm not supporting Joe
Biden I know lots of people in our
audience aren't supporting Joe Biden the
way to help somebody other than Biden
win in the primary is not to tell the
lie that the polls are bogus because
they're only polling old people it's
just not true and it's a real problem
that I have to do this segment today and
we're gonna talk through it one piece at
a time
first of all the people who have lost
the most from Joe Biden running who were
polling more than one or two to begin
with I mean if you're an establishment
Democrat who was polling one or two
before Biden announced I mean you're
just dead okay you're done but Bernie
Warren Budaj edge and beto are the four
candidates who have sort of trailed in
their polling trail off in their polling
to some degree the differing degrees
since Joe Biden made the announcement
that he's running this is in particular
what we have on the screen showing this
from the morning consult poll here's
their methodology which I admit to you
is is sort of opaque they say quote our
Democratic primary results are reported
using fifteen thousand seven hundred
seventy interviews with registered
voters who indicate they may vote in the
Democratic primary or caucus in their
state for those who say don't know or no
opinion they're asked to pick a
candidate they are leaning towards
results are reported among first choice
and those who lean towards a candidate
the interviews were collected from April
29 to May 5 margin of error of 1% okay
so if we look at this one they're not
exactly giving us they're not
at all the age demographics and sampling
they are including people who say they
are supporting a candidate and those who
say they're not sure if they're voting
but if they did here's the candidate
they're leaning towards so let's just
forget about the morning consult poll
altogether okay
let's look at the hill Harris X poll
which was conducted from a three to four
with a thousand registered voters and a
nationally representative sample the
results are very similar to others in
fact they're even better for Joe Biden
Biden is up big followed by Bernie mayor
Pete and then Elizabeth Warren and check
out the age sampling now it's true that
Biden does better with old people than
he does with young people but this is a
proper age sample so unless you believe
that they're lying about the age
sampling it is not something that we
benefit from to claim that Biden is only
leading when you only pull old people
let's look at another recent poll the
Harvard Harris poll published on May 1st
which has Joe Biden at 44% you once
again look at the sampling and there's
proper sampling of gender there's proper
sampling of education and race and
political party and political ideology
and age okay so listen I want a
progressive to win the primary I'm not
supporting Joe Biden I'm not trying to
help Joe Biden win if we want a
progressive to win lying that the polls
with Biden ahead don't poll young people
is not going to help get somebody else
elected as the Democratic nominee over
Joe Biden make the case that young
people and old people should support
somebody who's more progressive than Joe
Biden okay that's a real conversation
that we can actually have and we can win
on the issues talk about why these age
divisions exist why is it that Joe Biden
does less and less well with younger and
younger groups but what do we gain
by just making up that Biden's lead is
only because they are polling only old
people I just showed you two recent
polls where Biden is crushing and they
they pulled young people they have a
proper representative age sample it's
not true and it doesn't help us get a
progressive elected to claim that the
polls are only polling old people so
just stop saying it okay here's the data
let's actually make issue based
arguments about who we should be
supporting